geography is the visible condensation of
time it is literally all that we have of
time it somehow when you have so much of
it that you have to pile it up you get
geography and time is very much what the
psychedelic experience is about it's
about you know the time of your life the
time of the species but also the time of
the stones and when I delineated us as
being caught between geography and
language that's what I wanted to say
geography is the most condensed and
[Music]
Titanic
form of time and language is the most
thorough theory alized and present form
of time and you know the trick is to
realize that in the way that James Joyce
must have realized it because he
understood you know that speech ranks
mountains which is essentially what I'm
saying and I think this is a shamanic
idea the power of speech and the
awareness of eternity these are the two
things because the shaman really does I
think when you get it out of aura out of
you know these outlandish languages that
are not even literate languages they've
only been assigned alphabets for
purposes of study when you get these
concepts out of those languages and into
some kind of photonic or Aristotelian or
a galleon or hide Aguirre and vocabulary
which we can understand then you see
that that's what it's about it's about
standing and eternity and this is what
gives them their superhuman status
probably most of you are familiar with
mere silly odds book shamanism the
archaic techniques of ecstasy well this
is the book to read not because
everything it says is true and in fact
I'll delineate my differences with it
but because it represents a compendium
phenomenological approach where without
judge
the world is surveyed in an ordered
fashion and the case is actually put in
perspective so that we can for the first
time see that these diverse magical
religious practices of practitioners
that exist all over the world at a
certain cultural level and have a
certain congruence of belief are
actually part of a worldwide proto
historical religious system that is in
fact probably the foundation of all
religions because once you understand
the shamanic complex it's very easy then
to see how later religions like Hinduism
Jainism all of them rise on a foundation
of shamanic motifs
so that and and Iliad investigates and
delineates the shamanic motifs as some
of them are ability superhuman ability
to handle fire shamanic flight ability
to cure which you mentioned which is the
primary social function of the shaman
which really I think puts in perspective
the fad of shamanism which has enveloped
dark culture recently because our stress
largely though not entirely is on what
the shaman experiences for themselves
but in these societies where shamanism
is indigenous it is for the curing it's
almost as though the the vision is the
private payoff for being able to cure
and this is the function that the shaman
is fulfilling these superhuman abilities
by the ability to handle hot metal
ability to find lost objects ability to
foretell weather ability to cure
diseases are very challenging
to Western anthropology and they always
have been because we can't quite come to
grips with it and there have been
various ideas about it the most
promising ones I think leaning on the
idea that the linguistic context somehow
sets you up for how you perceive reality
but in what exactly this linguistic
context consists we haven't really been
able to discover but linguistic context
becomes extremely plastic under the
influence of hallucinogens where in fact
the word can become flesh almost
literally and are we have to remember
when talking about what you can do with
how a sentence that our approach is when
we take them I think most of us largely
scientific which is take the drug do as
little as possible this is known as not
interfering with the experiment and see
what happens and this is a very useful
technique that's the one that I favor
most of the time because I like my life
pretty much the way it is and don't see
Titanic transformations but if you take
these things and do things dance swing
through the trees expose yourself to
Wilderness isolation and that sort of
thing I think it's pretty clear you can
fairly quickly reach a place where other
people have very little to say to you
because our reality is link is a
linguistic net which holds us all
together and when you leave the net you
become what is conventionally known as
crazy because you become
pletely to the workings of a reality
which is different from other people's
you